[Musica]
allora eccomi a parlare di un argomento
un po scomodo ma che comunque se
parliamo di post umanesimo dobbiamo
comunque in qualche modo entrarci e
allora la sessualità in particolare il
sesso come cambia la cultura sessuale
nell'era del post umanesimo nel discorso
del tu sul post umanesimo allora intanto
molti di noi pensiamo di saperne tanto
sul sesso perché diamo per scontato che
il sesso sia un elemento della nostra
natura quindi che sia un elemento
naturale allora proviamo fare
un'indagine qua in platea
quanti di voi pensano di sapere sul
sesso tutto quello che c'è da sapere
alzate le mani
ecco allora benissimo quindi curiosi di
imparare allora andiamo a vedere perché
in fondo il sesso non è poi così
naturale come noi lo immaginiamo intanto
perché facciamo un paragone con il cibo
allora da stamattina da quando vi siete
svegliati avete bevuto il vostro caffè o
a pranzo avete mangiato il vostro piatto
un primo secondo
nulla di cui vi siete nutriti e davvero
innaturale perché chiaramente ha subito
un processo di lavorazione di conoscenza
e di sapere che della nostra specie
dell'homo sapiens la stessa cosa quindi
noi potremmo dire allora mangiare è un
atto naturale ma è una pratica filtrata
da tutta una serie di azioni culturali
culturali tecnologiche e che implicano
appunto una conoscenza ed è la stessa
cosa succede con la sessualità il sesso
certo che è parte della nostra natura
ma come lo pratichiamo come lo viviamo
le regole sessuali anche che noi ci
diamo dipendono dalla nostra cultura
allora questo ci introduce subito nel
tema della biodiversità umana e
soprattutto della bio diversità sessuale
nel senso che noi possiamo dire
l'antropologia ci insegna che attraverso
lo so
lazio attraverso il tempo i costumi
sessuali degli esseri umani di homo
sapiens che a 150 mila anni più o meno
sono davvero diverse dipendono
tantissimo dal rapporto tra l'uomo e
l'ambiente
per esempio qualcosa di cui non si parla
mai e la poliandria la poliandria è un
modello di sessualità è chiaramente
anche un modello di coppia molto lontano
da quello a cui siamo normalmente
abituati a pensare cioè una donna che
sposa più uomini oppure vedete le modulo
queste sono donne cinesi hanno un
comportamento sessuale abbastanza
singolare e cioè scelgono i partner
sessuali a seconda del loro piacere e
eventuali figli che verranno concepiti
dal rapporto sessuale saranno cresciuti
nelle famiglie delle donne e quindi
avranno come unica figura di riferimento
maschile lo zio materno quindi la figura
del padre non esiste per questo tipo di
società si chiama società poliedrica
matriarcale ecco allora il l'attuale
andria perché si è diffusa vi dico
soltanto che la poliandria è sicuramente
un sistema di famiglia di relazione
molto molto poco diffuso in realtà per
la nostra specie e perché è un
adattamento dei posti dei luoghi che
sono luoghi molto difficili da lavori da
da prendere risorse quindi che non danno
da mangiare sono luoghi per esempio il
come le alture del tibet in cui le
famiglie poliandri che tendono a ridursi
chiaramente una donna con più uomini fa
o quanti figli al massimo 10 se
sopravvivono chiaramente nel corso della
sua vita fertile e questo fa sì che
allora sia una società davvero molto
piccole siano società che in qualche
modo non si espandono ma si ritraggono
il modello opposto ovviamente quello
della polizia c'è un uomo con più donne
ecco questo è il modello vincente per la
nostra specie perché la politica è stata
diffusa per lo
90 per cento delle società umane quindi
è il modello assolutamente prevalente
perché chiaramente perché un uomo con
più donne ad altri volti più figli e
questo vuol dire che il clan familiare è
composto fino a un numero anche di 50 60
individui e quindi una società che si
espande laddove c'è stato bisogno di
controllare controllare la terra o di
lavorarla allora il modello policinico è
stato quello prevalente
ecco allora abbiamo dato una idea
veramente molto così in fondo un po
superficiale delle differenze tra
sistemi familiari ma anche modelli
sessuali differenze che però sono
davvero molteplici abbiamo dato quelle
più famose e la polizia e la poliandria
ma c'è un'altra situazione che dovremmo
sottolineare cioè come ci siamo evoluti
noi dal punto di vista sessuale
allora molto prima di diventare
stanziali cioè di diventare delle degli
agricoltori e degli allevatori avevamo
una diciamo usavamo il sesto come
collante sociale questo significa che il
sesso ci serviva
quasi a tenere insieme delle piccole
comunità quando qualcuno si arrabbiava
molto più facile fare l'amore che fare
la guerra per esempio è quasi sempre il
test era esattamente come il cibo di
nuovo cioè ci si scambiava a cibo come
regalo come anche modo di accattivarsi
la benevolenza di qualcuno è la stessa
cosa ci si scambiava il sesso il curi
paco del brasile sono una popolazione
che abbiamo conosciuto ancora negli anni
70 del novecento per esempio loro
avevano un tipico comportamento che gli
antropologi considerano sicuramente
quello prevalente nell'antichità nella
preistoria e cioè tanti uomini
condividevano le stesse donne perché
pensavano che l'unico modo per una donna
di rimanere incinta era quello di avere
diciamo il seme di tutti quanti quindi
che il bambino rete nè se la forza di
tutti gli uomini della comunità
a un certo punto però c'è stato un
cambiamento e cioè la sessualità e il
senso di morale si sono sposati cioè dal
sesso
ha difeso anche tutta una serie di
valori come l'etica come appunto la
morale e quando è successo questo
esattamente 13.000 anni fa con la
rivoluzione del neolitico qua vedete
dietro le mie spalle proprio la coppia
del neolitico trovata a mantova a una
coppia che sepolta insieme in un
abbraccio si chiamano gli amanti appunto
ecco ecco che il neolitico ci da questa
nuova idea di sesso e morale motter che
ebbe perché il neolitico introduce
qualcosa di nuovo nella nostra specie
non in tutto il mondo chiaramente ma
soltanto nell'area in cui questa
rivoluzione avviene che il medio oriente
e con il neolitico nasce anche la
proprietà privata perché chiaramente
perché l'uomo alle romo suckers diventa
stanziale comincia a coltivare la terra
a rilevarli animali li deve trasmettere
di generazione in generazione come fa a
trasmetterli chiaramente deve sapere chi
sono i suoi figli e come fa a saperlo
chiaramente deve cominciare a regolare
la sessualità in modo molto diverso
rispetto a quello che abbiamo detto del
curi pacco del brasile sono società di
cacciatori raccoglitori che non hanno
una proprietà privata vivono di caccia e
di raccolta ed è tutto molto immediato
di giorno in giorno non c'è un accumulo
nel momento in cui diventiamo invece
stanziale allora accumuliamo abbiamo
bisogno di trasmettere la proprietà e il
controllo sulla sessualità e in
particolare quella femminile è
assolutamente imprescindibile per avere
appunto la sicurezza che i figli siano
del padre
allora questa panoramica davvero molto
veloce sulla storia della sessualità
della nostra specie
ci porta però ai tempi più contemporanei
anche perché dobbiamo parlare di posto
ma nesimo e dobbiamo quindi fare un
salto nella storia
allora abbiamo detto 13.000 anni fa il
neolitico e la ri la rivoluzione appunto
del diventare stanziali che porta anche
e accompagna anche la nascita delle
grandi religioni
c'è anche questo paragone tra la donna e
la terra pensate si trova questo
paragone nel vangelo nelle torah ebraica
e anche nel corano che recita proprio un
verso in cui mette proprio la donna come
fosse un in parallelo un paragone
proprio come se fosse la terra quindi
questo paragone tra la donna e la terra
sicuramente una reminescenza di questa
rivoluzione del neolitico
andiamo per un'altra rivoluzione
sessuale nella storia e della
rivoluzione che ci porta a liberarci
delle conseguenze dell'atto sessuale e
cioè ad un certo punto
l'introduzione degli di massa anche del
mercato degli anticoncezionali fa sì che
in qualche modo il controllo del
prodotto della sessualità sia sempre
meno importante perda di forza e questa
rivoluzione infatti dall'imperativo
procreativo al piacere femminile ci dice
qualcos'altro anche ci dice che il
piacere femminile in qualche modo può
essere messo sul tavolo pubblico perché
è sganciato dalla riproduzione cioè
legittimo per una donna fare o praticare
la sessualità senza che questo abbia una
una conseguenza negli ultimi 40 50 anni
dunque per noi homo sapiens
contemporanei è diventato normale
sganciare la sessualità dall'effetto
immediato che era quello della
procreazione e questo ha fatto sì che
alcune delle regole anche morali
che hanno segnato diciamo il controllo
sulla sessualità stiano venendo meno e
ci sono in particolare degli effetti sia
sul corpo umano che sul corpo sociale
sul corpo umano per esempio la chirurgia
estetica negli ultimi anni sta lavorando
tantissimo sulla intervento sugli organi
genitali per farli sembrare sempre più
come dire imperfetti o appetibili
secondo canoni estetici quindi è
soggetto a delle mode il corpo umano
soggetto alle mode attraverso anche
appunto l'intervento di chirurgia
estetica e poi sono cambiati anche i
modelli di corteggiamento delle donne
diventano sempre più predatrice abbiamo
messo sul tavolo il piacere femminile
attraverso la rivoluzione degli
anticoncezionali allora anche abbiamo
sdoganato la donna predatrice e quindi
anche questo perseguimento del piacere
in ultimo importantissimo e il
collegamento tra sesso e felicità cioè
il sesso è entrato nella categoria del
well being cioè del benessere la
sessualità intesa come esattamente
pratica di nuovo come il cibo che è
legata allo stato di salute allora
quanti rotocalchi quante trasmissioni ci
parlano di come conquistarlo di è come
avere una vita figlio sessuale felice
come migliorarla e i sessuologi
terapisti insomma tutti che parlano di
come gestire questo aspetto della vita
proprio perché è legato alla salute
gli effetti sul corpo sociale dei
effetti sul corpo sociale sono evidenti
questa diciamo sgretolarsi del causa
effetto procreato e procreazione fa sì
che vengano meno per esempio alcuni
legami che hanno fondato questi 13mila
anni di storia che sono per esempio il
matrimonio che in calo o per esempio
anche l'aumento di famiglie diverse da
quelle che abbiamo conosciuto non sono
nè l'emo suo della cina non sono neanche
i sistemi politici ma se una famiglia
sempre
più fatte di un solo genitore con i
propri figli oppure addirittura di un
solo individuo per famiglia quindi
famiglie di individui in ultimo le
famiglie ricomposte quindi non c'è più
il dato biologico che lega le persone
dentro la stessa casa ma sempre più
legami che dipendono da altre cose che
non sono necessariamente la biologia
ecco allora panoramica sugli effetti sul
corpo umano e sul corpo sociale e
soprattutto una novità assoluta è che la
sessualità che piano piano si
smaterializza perché può anche come dire
essere soddisfatto attraverso nuovi
mezzi come nella relazione uomo macchina
questo è il film di spike jones
ecco nel film share questa persona il
protagonista un uomo molto sole in
realtà si innamora di una intelligenza
artificiale che non ha un corpo ed è
proprio l'assenza di corpo che rende
diciamo questo amore così forte e anche
in un certo senso erotico c'è e nel
momento in cui si tenta di dare un corpo
questo tipo di sentimento allora proprio
invece c'è proprio il grande fallimento
di questa storia d'amore per chi ha
visto il film allora ci sono due
tendenze del corpo e della sessualità
nella nostra contemporaneità la prima
tendenza è quella che ci piace
smaterializzarsi quindi di poter avere
anche delle relazioni che sono
esclusivamente virtuali o che avvengono
attraverso l'etere e allo stesso tempo
però come nel caso del robot sofia
vogliamo che l'intelligenza artificiale
i nostri computer assomiglino sempre di
più anche fisicamente
all'uomo infatti il robot sofia che è
stato presentato l'anno scorso
esattamente le fattezze di una donna
perché mettere un robot
a dare un robot dalle fattezze femminili
così marcate allora questo è un po il
grande tema la bilancia tra la
smaterializzazione del corpo e la ri
materializzazione delle informazioni e
dell'intelligenza artificiale
allora come concludiamo questa nostro
top beh sicuramente dicendo che
attraverso la conoscenza della
biodiversità sessuale consapevoli che la
cultura è più che la natura a
determinare nostre scelte sessuali
noi dovremmo in qualche modo ripensare
attraverso la conoscenza e sapere al
nostro modo di relazionarci con l'altro
anche dal punto di vista sessuale
grazie
[Applauso]